I figure you guys are really really good
so I could take a very very difficult
subject and try to make it easy for you
so one of the things that we try to do
it's not always so easy as we try to
coordinate our pieces we had tried to
bring them in harmony with each other
and in this position how many of you
know how to check mate with a bishop and
night do you we're going to learn what
what's going to happen is the class
that's you guys that's you guys are
going to play the white pieces and I I'm
going to play the black King so I'm
gonna move with the black King and you
guys are going to coordinate your three
pieces your King your Bishop and your
knight to try to checkmate my King but
first of all we have to think about it
conceptually for just a moment the
concept now for you to checkmate my King
by definition you cannot check my king
when it's in the center you're going to
have to force my King into one of the
corners okay so the first concept that
you have to understand with white is
that you have to drive my King into the
corner
that's concept number one concept number
two the only way for white to checkmate
my King is to put me on a LightSquared
corner so let's just imagine that you
managed to accomplish this position how
could you checkmate my king in
corner in tumors what would be yes young
man yes okay and that would prevent my
king from going into the corner check
that's correct
so now in this position I can't move my
king - any other square my only legal
square is a eight and now young man and
that is checkmate so this is the ideal
position that you want you have to drive
my King in the corner and as we've just
seen I don't know where I put mine as
we've just seen now you know that you
could checkmate meet on this square what
other square could you check make me on
and then correct those are the only two
light squares that the corners are light
squares so you know intellectually that
from this starting position that you
have to drive me isn't it the concept is
you have no choice you have to put my
king either on that square a8 or that
square H 1
but I'm very clever I'm very clever I
know that so my best defense is to try
stay either on this square h8 or this
square a1 because those are dark squares
and you cannot checkmate me on the dark
squares you have to use this Bishop to
checkmate me here on a 8 or here on h1
look at all of these squares your knight
protects these two squares so I will
play here okay
I want to stay close YZ these two
squares are my safe little burros and
I'm the rabbit and I'm running and I
want to stay close to home okay your
turn young men brilliant that is the
correct move because my king wants to
stay here so where it's at right now is
very good but also very good is this
square h7 because that's also closed so
when you play the move Bishop f5 which
is truly a brilliant move you stopped my
King from going to this square and I'm
forced to go to f8 so you guys are doing
really really well now remember a moment
ago you just denied mice king the h7
square which was excellent
you had better denying my king the g8
square because that g8 is close to H a
yes that's a good move is there a better
move young man did you have a suggestion
No
Knight to h8 that doesn't really help
because I go back to g8 and you'll
probably go back here so we will just
repeat so how can you protect this
square best young man that was just the
suggestion okay if you if you like that
move
that's okay I'll go King here young man
okay now isn't this familiar guess what
you drove me out of my burrow on h8
where do you think I'm going to run like
a rabbit - I run the rabbit like to a1
and here I go yeah that's what I want
yes now that's a check look where I'm
running okay let's go back because what
happened is you did a really good job at
pushing me away from this corner but
then you didn't keep me contained and I
went to that corner so what had happened
is you guys and you guys did really good
is you got this position and when my
king was here you made a mistake
you moved your Bishop to h7 and then I
ran look how I ran I went here and here
so this Bishop protects this square
right so try to find another move yes
brilliant
now you're coordinating Knight to h6 now
check this out my King cannot go to e7
it cannot go to f7 g7 or g8 my king
to go to e8 yes young men with the night
and then I go right back yes indeed
I certainly will night here King here
you guys did really good the night on g8
that's not a bad square
I like that square now I don't want to
go over here I want to stay over here so
I'll go King here young man yes that's a
wonderful move I like that move so I'm
going to allow yourselves to play it
that is a very very good move but let's
try to see what's going on now you've
done a good job you've cut my king away
from my safety this is my home and so is
this these are my two castle this is
where I want to be but you've driven me
now to this square e8 young man the
bishop is ideal the bishop is ideal
right now your knight should be on a
better Square your bishop is on the
ideal square because it protects me it's
prevents me pardon me from moving my
king here the bishop also prevents me
from running so your Bishop is good your
king at the moment is quite good
but your knight must be improved young
lad
excellent excellent excellent
Bravo give yourself a big pat on the
back
now after Knight to e7 I'm going to move
I want to stay here so I'm going to move
back now
your turn yes correct
Bravo now let's try to understand what's
going on now your Bishop and Knight are
coordinating beautifully together your
knight protects the e7 square the f8
square your Bishop protects f7 and g8
which means that all of these squares
are now protected by your minor pieces
furthermore your Bishop which is
beautifully placed guards d7 and it
guards c8 well done
but your King is now not on its best it
it's it's your turn
correct your turn why don't you do ah
but now when you move you you move your
king here you you stop my King from
coming but you've already done that with
your pieces if your King moves here my
king is going to try to escape so you
want your king to stop my king from
running over there young man what did
you think the best the very very very
best move King to e5 congratulations
that is the best move so now what your
king is trying to do is it wants to
intercept my king and stop me from
running over here okay I have no choice
I can't move my king here or here or
here or here I have to move my king here
oops
hahaha King - yes young men in the blue
yes you guys have done real excellent
choice excellent again notice how your
three pieces are working together and
you've limited my choice now I can't run
i oh i desperately desperately
desperately want to run to the a1 square
that you've cut me off completely
now you're you forced me to go King here
your choice your turn young man oh that
would be a good move except for one
small tiny detail I could yes young ah
but Bishop d7 allows me to go King f7
and I'm running back to this corner so
now remember what you want to do is stop
me from going here and you want to push
me here you want to push me in that
direction how can you do it you have to
use your King Bishop at night young man
that would be a great move except for
one small tiny detail I can't move yeah
a small tiny detail young man in the
back it's a draw stalemate as a draw you
have to give me the legal move and you
astound me means that you don't make a
victory young man in the blue your night
is perfect it stops my king from going
to these two squares young man what's
your move I
I'm going to I'm gonna give you guys a
hint your best move is to move your king
your best move is to move your king
where should you move your king that's a
good move but it's not your best move in
the back all the way
King sorry your king is on d6 correct
that is your best move
King to c6 now I have no choice I have
no choice whatsoever I have to move my
King to d8 now again you don't want me
going this way you want me going that
way so how can you prevent me from going
this way young man in the light blue yes
excellent excellent excellent move
Bishop f7 now notice how good your King
is here
it covers this square c7 this square d7
and this square b7 your Bishop protects
the e8 square your knight protects the
e7 square I have no choice I must play
King to c8 and now young man in the
bathroom
correct night East seven check I want to
stay away from this corner I will go
here young man in the blue while you
just came from g6 so I'll go back no
harm no foul
what's the best move young man Bishop to
e6 check I will move my King back young
man your king is on its best square
right now your bishop your King is on
its best square your bishop is on its
best square which leaves you with a clue
your Knights not on its best square
young man yes Knight East seven check
that is correct
King has to go here and now
yes sorry in the back this would be a
great move a great move except for one
small tiny detail it's very good so
stalemates not good so we're going to
have to move our night where should we
move our night now let's do a different
kind of concept here we've done really
good we have pushed the king away all
the way over towards this corner so
we've just got to push it a little bit
further so we first we're going to
reposition our Knight where do we
reposition our Knight young man
excellent
that is the best square we reposition
the Knight to d5
notice that from the d5 square which is
an excellent square we cover b6 and c7
that might not feel very important at
this moment but it does prevent our King
in the future from trying to run around
the curve and all the way over here so
let's say I play King here okay
young man
to where the king is on c6 to where
knight to e7 we were just there
that would that's where we just came
from young man yes okay that's an
excellent move now what I want to try to
do is I want to try to escape how on
earth can I escape my fate let me try to
go King to be set to escape let me try
to escape
young man Bishop to eat a t' that is a
good move now notice in this position
that this bishop controls this square
and this square and this square this
Knight controls this square so if I try
to bring my King here your two pieces
stop me from running in that direction
and that's very very good
for you so let me go King here yes young
man in blue yes okay Knight to c7 is
okay I will go King here and now
remember don't let me run away young man
Bishop to c6 okay that's good I'll move
my king here and I'm dreaming that
you're going to allow me to escape I'm
dreaming young man in the blue yes
Oh
be very careful after night to b5 I'm
going to move my king and I'm gonna try
to run away and man in the booth correct
excellent loop Knight to d5 check is
correct let me move my king back to a7
and now it's your turn it's tough isn't
it this is one of the most difficult
endings from your normal Czech mating
patterns young man your knight your
Bishop are perfect okay the problem that
you have at the moment is with your king
your king can be improved at the moment
your Bishop and Knight protect D this D
squares so the King can't run you've got
to just keep the King here for the time
being
how do you do that young man okay King
to c7 is good and after King here
yes in there okay but after Knight b6
King here be very very careful now I
want to move my king here and to run
away so you have to guard this square
now you'll have to go back and I will go
back okay
what now and you remember I'm trying to
teach you something new came back to d6
that's okay and let's say I go back with
the King here yes young man excellent
excellent
okay so now King to c5 very very good
okay now I'm afraid you you've managed
to box me in so I can't run away like
this because the bishop controls that
square and your knight controls these
two squares I am afraid that you box me
in I'm going to go King here knight on
d5 where to be for well then I'm just
going to move my king okay young man
you're you watch it your Bishop and
Knight are perfect it's your king that
you need to improve it's your king yes
again your knight and Bishop are perfect
it's your king that needs smooth King
before thank you I have no choice I must
move my king young man
okay excellent now you really are
coordinating incredibly well right now
your Bishop and Knight are still perfect
your King can still be improved young
man correct okay now you've achieved the
ideal position for your King Bishop and
night but still having achieved that
doesn't mean that you've won the game
I'll play King here you have yes young
man okay but after the bishop goes to b7
I'm going to try to run away like this
yes yeah okay Knight to e7 check I have
no choice I must move here young man oh
I'm not tacking your knight okay Knight
to d5 I have to go back with my king
it's tough isn't it it's a very very
very tough ending yes young man okay
King to c5 let's say I go King to d8
very good so far you guys are doing
great young men
okay excellent excellent move King to d6
I have to move my king yes our young
king to e7 I have to move my king I I
would think maybe here there is a better
move so one of the things that you're
having trouble with is my King keeps
moving here to d8 imagine that this
Knight
how could this Knight defend or control
this square Knight to f6 doesn't help
you control this square so this square
for control the square with the night
young man 97 check doesn't help because
I still go to d8 so I'm looking for a
different move young man King East 7
just pushes me around I use this night
this night control this square young man
excellent excellent 97 King to d8 and
now you're doing really really really
well just bring this night control this
square d8 we're young man excellent now
now let's see what's going on after king
here this night controls this square and
this square c7 and d8 this Bishop which
is perfect controls b7 a8 and d7 so
after night so you have to now improve
your king how do you do that young man
excellent
that was the move I wanted to hear King
to b8 only choice the only choice
young men excellent now you guys have
finally it's so hard but the whole
purpose of this exercise is one thing
and one thing only learning to
coordinate the three pieces learning to
coordinate the King Bishop and night so
that they work in harmony together this
is one of the most difficult things in
chess is to make sure that your pieces
are coordinating and now you've got the
perfect position I'm going to play King
to c8 and now what would you like to do
that would be a good move except for one
small tiny detail just a small tiny
detail I did you with the king yes now
you're really close to the checkmate so
what you want you what you want to do is
push me here and then push me here now
right now if you look at the position my
next move if it was my turn
I'd have to go here I'd have to go here
so you have to wait one move you have to
make a passing look young man in the
blue yeah Bishop b7 lets me escape okay
okay so you're just a few moves away
from checkmate in the back yes you young
men excellent excellent excellent move
you just wait you've you now in this
moment my King can't go to d8 because
you're very clever you put your knight
on e6 my king can't go to c7 because
you're very clever you covered that
square I have to go to b8 now deny me
this square young man excellent
excellent excellent excellent that is
the correct move and it's brilliant now
let's think about this you you finally
pushed me not into the castle but into
the moat do you know what the mode is
right around the castle I'm about to
drown here you guys are like about to
checkmate me I'll play King to a8 that's
my only choice young man what are you
right that Bishop to c6 check
here you haven't made a progress
excellent excellent that's a check
I can't move my king here I can't move
my king here I must move my king to b8
and now it's checkmate in two moves
checkmate in two moves young man one
small tiny detail I can't take it
young man correct and now the coup de
Gras you guys don't see it huh check and
mate how big how difficult is this
ending how difficult this ending is your
king not in the final position though
look how beautiful the harmony is the
night it covers a square the King it
covers a square the Bishop it covers two
so this is a checkmate you'll be shocked
that recently in a tournament in Europe
there was the women's Grand Prix and the
Women's Champion world champion didn't
make the checkmate and 50 moves and less
remember there's a 50 move rule in chess
and so she didn't achieve it this class
you had a lot of trouble you pushed me
from from this corner all the way to
this corner then you push me all the way
back before you managed to push me over
here
but I think you did it in less than 50
members